>>> RIGHT NOW THE WHITE HOUSE IS
COLLEGE LOANS AS THEURRENT
PAUSE ON MOST FEDERAL STUDENT
LOANAYMENTS IS SET TO EXPIRE
AT T END OF THIS MONTH.
CNN'S NEW REPORTING OVERNIGHT IS
THAT OFFICIALS ARE LEANING
TOWARD CANCELING UP TO $10,000
IN DEBT FOR BORROWERS WHO MAKE
LESS THAN $125,000 A YEAR.
THIS DECISION COULD COME AS SOON
AS TOMORROW.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT.
IT IS GOOD TO HAVE YOU, MARK,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> SO I READ THROUGH ALL YOUR
ANALYSIS AND BASICALLY IT SHOWS
THAT CANCELING THIS STUDENT LOAN
DEBT FOR FOLKS WOULD UNDERMINE
THE INFLATIONARY WORK THAT THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT IS SET
TO DO.
AND WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTS IT TO DO.
WHY?
WHY DO THEY CANCEL EACH OTHER
OUT?
>> WELL, SO THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT SAVES MAYBE $300
BILLION IN THE FIRST TEN YEARS.
IF WE GIVE -- CANCEL $10,000 OF
DEBT AND EXTEND THE PAUSE A FEW
MONTHS, WE'LL BE AT THAT MUCH IN
TERMS OF CAUSE.
ALL THE DEFICIT REDUCTION WILL
BE WIPED OUT.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE'RE PROBABLY
GOING TO DO MORE TO INCREASE
INFLATION FROM DEBT CANCELLATION
THAN ANY INFLATION REDUCTION
FROM THE INFLATION REDUCTION
ACT.
>> SO I WANT TO GET TO THE
SECOND POINT YOU MADE, AND THAT
IS, YOU KNOW, WHAT IS
INFLATIONARY AND WHAT IS
DISINFLATIONARY.
SO THERE ARE A BUNCH OF
ECONOMISTS, MARK ZANDI AT
MOODY'S, AND HEIDI SHAREHOLT,
WHO SAY THEY THINK YOU'RE WRONG,
AND LET ME TALK ABOUT SHAREHOLT,
WHO WORKED IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, SHE SAYS YOUR
ANALYSIS IS PROFOUNDLY OFF BASE
AND THE REASON SHE SAYS THAT IS
SHE POINTS TO THE TWO PLUS YEAR
MORATORIUM WE ALREADY HAD ON
STUDENT DEBT PAYMENT, AND SHE
SAYS BASICALLY FOLKS HAVE HAD
THIS MONEY IN THEIR POCKETS FOR
TWO PLUS YEARS AND SO CANCELLING
THIS STUDENT LOAN DEBT WOULD NOT
EFFECTIVELY PUT MORE MONEY IN
THEIR POCKET RIGHT NOW.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> WHAT THE FOLKS ARE DOING IS
PRETENDING WE'RE GOING TO EXTEND
THIS PAYMENT PAUSE FOREVER.
AND IT IS TRUE.
COMPARED TO THE EXTENDING THE
EMERGENCY ERA PAYMENT -- IT
WOULD BE DISINFLATIONARY.
THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT COMPARISON.
THE RIGHT COMPARISON IS COMPARED
TO REPAYMENTS STARTING IN ABOUT
A WEEK AS SCHEDULED.
THIS IS ALWAYS MEANT TO BE A
TEMPORARY PAUSE.
IF IT IS A PERMANENT PAUSE, IT
IS NOT STUDENT DEBT, IT IS
STUDENT GRANTS.
>> WHAT COMPLICATES THIS PICTURE
FOR THE AVERAGE VIEWER WATCHING
RIGHT NOW IS THAT THEY'RE
DEALING WITH INFLATION NEAR A
40-YEAR HIGH, MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE GROCERIES, GAS HAS
COME DOWN, BUT MORE THAN WHAT
THEY'RE USED TO, MORE EXPENSIVE
HOUSING, TRANSPORTATION, I COULD
GO ON AND ON.
I WONDER IF YOU'RE CONCERNED THE
POSSIBILITY THAT RESTARTING THE
PAYMENTS IN A FEW DAYS WORSENS
THAT BURDEN ON AMERICANS
STRUGGLING WITH THIS INFLATION
IN THIS MOMENT.
THAT'S THE REALITY, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT IS
GOING TO DO.
IT IS NOT AS IF THIS IS GOING TO
LIFT INFLATION FROM 8% TO 9%.
WHAT THIS IS GOING TO DO IS MAKE
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR US TO GET
INFLATION DOWN TO 2% OR 3%,
WHERE IT REALLY SHOULD BE.
IT IS GOING TO MAKE THE FED'S
JOB HARDER AND IT WILL INCREASE
THE RISK THEY HAVE TO DRIVE US
INTO A RECESSION TO GET
INFLATION UNDER CONTROL.
>> BUT IT IS ALSO GOING TO MEAN
ANOTHER BILL, SIGNIFICANT
MONTHLY BILL FOR SOME FOLKS ON
TOP OF THEIR HIGHER BILLS
BECAUSE OF INFLATION RIGHT NOW,
RIGHT?
AND YOU'RE SAYING THAT'S A
BURDEN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
TO BEAR GIVEN THE OTHER NEGATIVE
EFFECTS IN YOUR ANALYSIS?
>> THAT'S SORT OF THE CATCH-22
OF THIS ALL.
WE COULD SEND EVERYBODY ANOTHER
ROUND OF CHECKS TO PAY FOR THEIR
INFLATION, BUT THAT WOULD MAKE
INFLATION WORSE.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS GET
INFLATION UNDER CONTROL.
ONE OF THE EASIEST WAYS TO DO
THAT IS TO ASK PEOPLE TO START
PAYING BACK THE DEBT THEY
ALREADY OWE, MAKE THE PRINCIPLE
PAYMENTS THEY ALREADY AGREED TO
AND BY THE WAY WHILE NOT
EVERYBODY THAT HAS STUDENT DEBT
IS RICH, DISPROPORTIONATELY
STUDENT DEBT IS HELD BY PEOPLE
THAT HAVE ADVANCED DEGREES AND
PRETTY GOOD INCOME AND THEY CAN
BEAR IT A LOT MORE THAN EVERYDAY
AMERICANS THAT ARE SEEING THE
COST OF THEIR GASOLINE AND
CLOTHING GO UP.
>> YOUR ANALYSIS POINTS TO
WEALTHIER HOUSEHOLDS WITH
MEDICAL DEGREES OR JDs,
ATTORNEYS.
I THINK THE CAP AT $125,000 A
YEAR WOULD CUT SOME OF THOSE
FOLKS OUT, NOT ALL, BUT SOME
FOLKS OUT.
ONE OTHER THING I THOUGHT WAS
JUST INTERESTING FROM WHAT YOU
GUYS LOOKED AT HERE IS YOU FOUND
THAT STUDENT LOAN CANCELLATION
WOULD NOT SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASE
THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP.
I'M WONDERING IF YOU COULD SPEAK
TO WHETHER YOU THINK THERE IS A
MORE TARGETED APPROACH THAT
WOULD BE MORE EFFECTIVE.
>> THE ISSUE IS DEBT
CANCELLATION MAY REDUCE THE
RACIAL WEALTH GAP BETWEEN TWO
RICH DOCTORS, A RICH BLACK
DOCTOR AND RICH WHITE DOCTOR,
BUT DISPROPORTIONATELY, THE 87%
OF AMERICANS WHO DIDN'T GO TO
COLLEGE ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THIS WOULD WIDEN IT OVERALL.
A MORE TARGETED APPROACH WOULD
FOCUS ON INCOME-DRIVEN PAYMENTS
AND COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
THAT MEANS PUSHING COLLEGE TO
ACCEPT MORE AP CREDITS AND
TRANSFERS FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, MORE NO FRILLS
DEGREES, CUTTING O